Esta es una de las tantas posiciones que
hay a lo largo de la línea de defensa de
las posiciones de bucle dark y marinca
es una posición que dedicada al sistema
portable antimisiles de defensa y su
misión de estos hombres es proteger que
todo lo que se lanza desde el cielo a
menos de 500 metros de altura esto
incluye misiles drones helicópteros
alcance las posiciones de sus compañeros
que se encuentran protegiendo estas
poblaciones en las calles todo lo que
envían suele volar en un Rango entre 50
y 100 metros por eso es que los an
radares no pueden verlos Esta es la
importancia de esas defensas portátiles
efectivas para destruir al enemigo
al comienzo de la guerra volaban por
aquí como si fuera su casa porque no
teníamos estas unidades aéreas de
defensa aquí pero luego logramos
derribar un par de helicópteros Y jets
por eso ahora Ellos tienen más cuidado
en cruzar nuestras líneas
estos hombres que han visto mayor
actividad de misiles y drones en las
últimas semanas en una respuesta de las
fuerzas rusas a esa contraofensiva que
planean las fuerzas ucranianas Ellos
dicen que es como si ellos estuvieran
haciendo todo lo posible por encontrar
esas bases militares donde se encuentran
no solamente las armas sino las
municiones Claro que podemos sentir el
incremento y para nosotros es Claro que
esto está relacionado con la
contraofensiva Ellos tienen miedo
también están preocupados pero hay que
dejarlos de sentir de esa manera Hay que
dejarlos
nuestra misión es destruir los objetivos
enemigos aéreos en general son drones
kamikaces y otra clase de naves no
tripuladas nosotros somos móviles y
apoyamos en el rango del área que nos
corresponde
este tipo de defensas aéreas jugarán un
papel fundamental en lo contraofensiva
que planean las tropas ucranianas porque
ellos serán quienes apoyarán a la
Infantería que estará ganando terreno y
recuperando sus territorios ocupados por
Rusia